foreign
[Music]
welcome back to careful boys everybody
we got a special episode because we have
a very cool story that uh was actually
sent in and then I did some digging and
saw how massive it really was but I
didn't think it was getting enough
coverage so this incredible story about
something that happened in the sneakers
Community I was like we got to get
somebody who really knows their [ __ ]
about it so today we got Norman lie in
the house hey
experience on what the [ __ ] happened in
this sneaker industry man uh so
basically there's this guy named Sade
Zade kicks um he's kind of like an OG in
the sneaker Community he resold on it is
he more OG than Fran Elations yeah Fran
Elations I don't know that is that's oh
gee dog relations is trash
he just made that up he's not OG it's
not like a book of the Bible that we
skipped over is he oh is he more OG than
Reebok Pumps though uh no he was
probably like 10 10 to 13 years ago how
do you started reselling so he's like
mini OG mini LG in the reselling World
he's pretty LG and people give this guy
millions of dollars to get shoes for
them right yeah how does it work he
that's the mystery yeah that's he he
resold on eBay before and I guess he got
his connects to there
um and then I'm I don't know if he got
connected to Nike or something but he
gets shoes for under retail or like
shoes for a really good deal if it's
like a hype shoe wow and so it could not
even exist yet they could just be like
announced and he's already taken
pre-orders and people are just throwing
money at him like yo when that comes out
I want it sent to my door and then
they'll just give them all this money
and they still don't know how he does it
and track record wise he's delivered on
that like let's say something like a
really hype shoe in 2015 or something
people put in a pre-order for a shoe
that didn't exist he delivered on those
shoes or it's just the accumulation of
fraud so he'll do it through like off
rumors that people make up like random
Instagram pages will make up a rumor and
he'll be like hey this might be it or
like SKU the skus like the shoe number I
guess if that comes out
um he'll do a pre-order on those and he
does deliver but it comes usually comes
within two to six months after the
release so Nike would have really
already released it and then two to six
months he'll get them all and then you
just send him out and he was doing that
for a good while until covet happened
and then that's when [ __ ] started to
really look fishy but wait were people
getting shoes yeah yeah oh they were
getting shoes you'd get them eventually
you get them eventually but then once
covered stuck then things started taking
a little longer can I can I tell you
what this conspiracy is what is it I
think I'm a detective so I know how to
figure out are you sure enough
information yet I got plenty dude
you could actually leave now
Crack the Case right now we'll take it
from here thank you it's an easy solve
he has a Vietnamese sweat shop in his
basement so every time there's a new
shoe release he gets the dimensions the
pictures and all that stuff and he goes
all right here you go train hook it up
Tango Atlanta oh my God [ __ ]
[ __ ] and he's 12. dude he's 12. he's
12. yeah that's good good things about
like you know 12 year old hands is
they're really small so the little holes
you need to make for the [ __ ] like
shoelaces perfect right that's what it's
perfect for those hands they're really
like surgical with that [ __ ] so they
make the new Jordans or whatever that
came out and it's like boom I got you
man and then they can't even tell a
difference because they're professional
how about that is that good
what do you think Norman huh how about
that I think the US is giving out too
much money because he's having trouble
finding people to work for him so those
those little Vietnamese what a nice
problem how about that huh how about
that all right all right continue the
story I failed so yeah um so he does he
was fulfilling a lot of orders and
they're all legit orders like they'll go
through like stockx and I go into all
those big big reselling or I guess those
stuff so get the box you get the barcode
certifiably it is a legit shoe every
time all right I'm a detective I got
this all right you got this you got this
come on you only get one try each you
guys by the way go ahead normally I
failed already
enough information
I already failed
but yeah so
deliver all those things like we'd get
them like they'd come to my apartment
and like this giant box you were in the
Cahoots with this criminal I'm buying
from him okay okay so you're the
customer what's the largest order you've
done just through him like money-wise
how much was it I had to run 80k in oh
my God yeah because it just I just had
just started my selling I guess like in
late or early 2019. do your parents
shoes
yeah wait but it must have been like you
started with like 5K or something it
just kept going and building it up right
yeah you didn't just go like 80k baby I
actually had a close friend of mine that
detective right he knew that he's the
he's the main guy that gets all the
orders from everybody so that's how I
got into it
um but I was just buying off like
everybody else on the Nike app sneakers
app and you've ordered from this dude
before yeah and I got everything so so
that was like where you felt like okay
and ordering 80k worth of shoes could be
turned into how much profit uh it
depends on what the releases were I had
one order it had about 30 Pairs and that
could have met me 30k in profit so you
make 80k to make 30k well I would have
put it I put in six thousand or six to
ten thousand so like a 5x Roi type you
need a business partner
you would have made like 300 000 no I
would have made 30k just from that one
order but there's a bunch of different
shoes so and it's it's kind of like a
gamble because you don't know how the
Market's gonna go up down right a shoe
market but at the time it's just it was
just going up so once pandemic hit what
started to happen with this guy
yeah he uh he started taking more orders
for better pricing that was the first
thing that I thought was weird yeah that
was the first red flag for me so I put a
little less I stopped going all the time
and then a lot of the hype shoes he
would never get he would always have the
general release shoes which the gr shoes
what they're called um which is shoes
that go into like foot sites like uh
Foot Locker like Finish Line and all
those other sites so it's not like a
special edition or limited release time
no but there's still profit for each
shoe like Jordan once was really popular
last year or yeah last year and the
dunks as well and each one can net you a
hundred dollars profit each wow so if
you were able to get however many even
if they're just like a regular color or
nothing special you can still net a
hundred like 50 to 100 each yeah damn
yeah so it was
um so he started taking more money
for orders yes well when covet happened
I stopped doing it because I wasn't sure
how everything was going to be like
smart guy and then so I only put like
10K more it was stuck never mind
just 10K yeah that's good it's still a
lot but yeah okay I wasn't that scared
yeah so you had a standing order with
this guy right yeah um so a lot of the
shoes weren't coming and it's already
been over a year and a half so whoa yeah
how do you answer to the customers or do
they are they already assigned to people
like people already put in a order
already this is just your own shipment
they don't really have like a recipient
everyone has their own order it's kind
of like just ordering online like
regular things
um and is it true that people who are
hassling him about their order he would
threaten to just block about life yep
instantly so you never is it normal to
like wait a while for the orders yeah
usually so it's normal so you're just
like ah it takes like three months it's
not like Amazon two to six months two to
six months what a year but yeah so after
the six months I was like okay this is
taking a little long so then it was like
yeah a year and a year and a half and
then
yeah it's it just got worse and worse
than else did you call customer service
yeah yeah they don't really work that
way damn I had well the guy that I know
he he deals directly with him and he has
like Millions with this guy so
um and he's taking because he's taking
orders from a lot of other people so
he's making money off the other people
and there's no there's also no
regulation for this type of business so
there's no one to answer to like if he
starts doing some shady [ __ ] you have no
one you can call me well I mean there's
no receipt yeah and this is called like
that resellers Mark is this considered a
reseller's mark yeah yes uh they call it
back door back door pre-ordering it's a
funny name
yeah very cool not because you can't
you're not supposed to bachelor's stuff
yeah you guys I remember there was a
dude I don't know if it was like bait or
like another another uh brand or
something like that that was back door
and stuff
um and then they lost their kids kids
yeah they lost they lost their like
account you know with the yeah because
that is an illegal thing A lot of people
do it so yeah so then one specific thing
happened that sent the internet and the
whole sneaker Community into a frenzy
what was that thing uh so he dissolved
his company oh and the incident that
happened like everyone like there was a
tour space instantly for it and like
there's I think like three or four
people in it just so that's like a like
a sneaker rug pull then pretty much yeah
like a little Ponzi scheme but how long
has he been doing it for he's been doing
this uh uh over 10 10 years so I mean it
was a legitimate business and something
happened and he couldn't fulfill was it
like a supply chain issue things that
was gonna affect everything anyway that
was going to go down so he just did one
last big job that he knew was gonna run
yeah what's going on I have no idea I
think it's because of Kobe that
everything kind of went downhill because
the shipments don't come in even Nike
releases
um they push back a lot of things every
time they'll say this will come out this
date they push it back another month but
he had already promised sales so he
probably just got himself really really
deep yeah but then at that point it was
like we're not gonna be able to deliver
so we might as well just like sell as
much as possible right now and balance
yeah that that's all that could be also
a thing too we don't know
um everyone's still trying to figure
that out so where is this guy he lives
up in Oregon
um and I think he's still next to Nike
yes what if it's Phil himself
is he an old man I heard he's bored
these days he doesn't look that old
maybe like 40s but no no it doesn't look
bad I mean just straight to Phil Knight
I would have gotten away with it you JK
idiots
yeah so he he's I think he's still
around because there's as soon as that
happened like that same day I think he
called the cops to ask for police
protection
yeah the weird things people were going
to his house oh so people know who he is
specifically well he's very present
online like he flexes a lot of [ __ ] he's
got cars he's got all this stuff like
he's not an invisible dude yeah he's one
of the so I think there's like three or
four big pre-order kind of guys yeah uh
I think he's one of them but he shows
off a lot like the other guys don't
really show off and he shows off a lot
but he deleted everything like all of
his pictures everything maybe that's why
he kept needing the money because he has
payments on all those things yeah he has
his own businesses too he has like a
weed company sounded very like a certain
parent yeah very sympathetic I
appreciate it the weird thing that I
thought was like I still can't wrap my
head around how this happened he was
able to dissolve his company through the
uh approval of a judge right yeah courts
so like the judge allowed him to do that
normally you can't but did you look if
you look at the judge he's wearing the
outfit right and go down to his feet
Travis Scott [ __ ] I see I see
okay we got the AstroWorld everyone in
there [ __ ] the police officers there
everyone's just laced up everybody
else's orders went to the judge everyone
in the jury yeah the flyest shoes in
there just [ __ ] off-white in Nike
Oregon even their [ __ ] thing it says
jury on their shoe so they just stayed
still don't know I know that was one of
the off-white juries
hey that's kind of that that sounds kind
of dope dude
damn they did it all for the Kicks When
the article that I was reading they were
still trying to figure out how the hell
he got that from a job yeah so a lot of
people are still trying to figure out
how he's well aside from that how he got
his shoes too because stock stockx I
think released something saying that um
or either that or they're backtrack
there they had like a portfolio thing
where they can see who bought the most
and the person at the very top that
bought the most was his wife yeah so
there might be taking everyone's money
and trying to fulfill other orders by
buying on stockx so they're just doing
something that anyone could have done
themselves anyways wow so that's just
like passing money back and forth that
kind of yeah and he's the middleman into
other businesses and stuff like that too
so what you're saying is there's
technically nothing wrong
I guess technically I guess
how much money are you personally out
like are you right now so last year at
the end of last year he actually
refunded us and I got back 30k so I
think I'm still at like 30 to 35k wow
wait so if you refund does that mean
like maybe he didn't try to [ __ ]
everybody like it maybe something really
should happen but he's actually still
kind of trying to fix certain things
even though like disappearing seems
weird yeah that's what I think too
because if you get a point in a receiver
receivers usually have to go and try to
refund all of the everybody else that he
borrowed money from so he borrowed money
not just from people like us and people
like me like Banks and certain other
investors and stuff like that too so
they have to refund all of them but
people like us we're just going to our
credit cards and like PayPal or whatever
and trying to get our money back
holy moly clusterfucker wow I wonder how
much he took uh I think it was over 100
million oh
sweatshops that's at least as of last
week when I was reading and watching
more videos that sounds like film night
for sure wow Phil nightclub to no good
dude only someone like Kim could pull
some [ __ ] like this off Phil Knight's
pretty big yeah
but you don't feel night though I kind
of have a feeling that he might be able
to pay off that 100 million like really
easy yeah like really really easy
he's still the prime suspect yeah what
do you think Anthony
you already know it's a different guy
it's not man I'm not sold
it's just his partner instead there's
the I think the VP of Nike or one of
something of the VP her son was doing
the reselling too and he yeah yeah I
heard about that yeah we did we did do
an article on that yeah he was an idiot
because he took photos with like stacks
of boxes like a [ __ ] but he blurred his
eyes out so it's fine
he put eyes
I think everyone knows what he looks
like already though because his face he
goes to like events and stuff like that
oh right are you still in the shoe game
or are you kind of like Madison kind of
burnt me out a little bit uh I still am
I buy just locally from here he's like
I'm never wearing these again
only so what's the next hustle I'm still
doing shoes because right now inside
this look kind of like stocks everything
that is low so I'm just buying stuff
that I know will eventually go back yeah
that's good that it didn't totally wipe
you out man no because there's probably
people that it did yeah do you know
people that are just [ __ ] demolished
yeah because they have like 700k 1
million in it 100 million a lot of money
yeah our little group we have around 1.2
wow so it's I got you beat I lost more
in Luna baby okay I heard
I felt so bad for you guys don't feel
bad he wears it like a trophy he likes
it he likes that I do I use my struggles
as [ __ ] honors uh Badges of Honor I
gotta use it to make more money you can
feel bad for me I don't talk about it
because it actually hurts yeah
he he got he got away with nothing I
said don't talk about it
so I actually hit up Michael you guys
you guys Michael asked me when you guys
had JK party to do I own a bowling alley
in Alhambra that bowling alley Alhambra
you own them you owned Alhambra Lanes
yeah yeah it's called Golden Mile
bowling wait wait is it the one by 168
market across the street yeah that's
yours
if you lost 30k you have a bowling alley
bro what the [ __ ] how did you how did
you come across that nobody cares about
the sneakers talk about the bowling
alley bro my dad owns the building and
then there's a lot of legal things and
we ended up taking over like nine nine
ten years ago and oh [ __ ] damn and I
just have my office in there with some
of my shoes so can we come bowl yeah
we're losing this office can we move
over to the bowling alley I try to help
Michael to do a JK party Michael you
[ __ ] up bro damn you told me you hit
me up and then later on no [ __ ] you
Michael we're gonna we're gonna jump on
them
I didn't mean to do this yeah I was
trying to get you guys do like 100 pins
man
that would have been a good JK party
episode oh my God what else do you own
dude yeah you own laser tag no
that's the only entertainment I got yeah
what about Disneyland huh yeah yo that's
for Steve how was the bowling alley
business during covid did you guys is it
a front is it a front I mean yeah
put my shoes
no uh the bowling alley business kind of
sucks right now I mean it's slowly dying
anyways but just the industry in general
yeah how about we revive it for you we
can revive it no we can't we will how do
we we will what does it need people to
have fun doing it more money it needs it
needs a new
I went to the bowling alley during uh
covid and then once you do it during
covid you have a completely different
new lens so remember like before covid
because you're touching all the same
balls exactly before it's like chicken
wings chili cheese fries
frostball so everyone you're just
[ __ ] his business right now
you said we'll help
and then you're like oh wait this wait
there's germs there's germs and [ __ ] but
then me I'm Chinese I don't give a [ __ ]
right so I'm still playing and [ __ ] but
then it just did give me a a quick
little
since day one I was like you know what's
more dangerous a gym where everyone's
touching stuff and the owner of the gym
is Chinese and doesn't give a [ __ ]
uh [ __ ] dude I guess I'm trying you said
don't give a [ __ ]
yeah very cool dude that's what I'm
talking about we bring the call better
we don't care everybody's Chinese
everybody's Chinese no I'm Chinese
Colleen Chinese
that's high 31.2 actually oh [ __ ] really
you're 31.2 she's more Chinese than I am
that's amazing you just look so white
yeah but not the third one you're saying
that with condolences in your voice
no actually my friend she's 50 Chinese
and you both have a similar cheek it's a
Chinese cheek oh yeah my friend is
trying to you have a nose too and two
eyes that's your wrestler news it says a
Chinese cheek the Chinese cheeks Colleen
the Chinese cheese this sounds like a
stripper name not the butt cheeks though
these ones
and we really are gonna go to the
bowling alley though dude let's go we're
gonna come that's gonna be so fun we've
been all hanging after the show so we're
gonna go and I'm gonna stick chili
cheese fries in the holes and eat them
out of them we don't really have food so
you can bring your own food and also
before you guys end up closing down this
dying dinosaur of a business can you hit
up Joe to see if he's willing to make a
stupid move and just buy it and then we
can hang out more I'm down all right
dude we really that's a good building
though one of my favorite restaurants is
there 101 noodle hell yeah how'd you
know everybody knows that's everyone's
favorite is that the only restaurant in
that building I know there's multiple
restaurants but that's like the popular
one yeah 101. dude we hope that you get
your money back from uh the day kicks
and uh talk about your uh your actual
sneaker business oh yeah I just made a
logo that looked like the Snickers candy
and it's just this is where I resell oh
yeah so you can just walk in there and
just buy a bunch of limiteds like what's
up what's the website that people can go
to no I just do it like on off-road oh
it's all online yeah okay so there's no
like brick and Morty place to watch
no I've tried to I wanted to get like
you know sponsored by them but that's a
sick ass uh collection so how do people
buy shoes off you they got to go to
offer up and look up Norman they working
in Highland Park there's no hamburgers
yeah I sell off Instagram mainly what's
your Instagram what's your insta oh
sneakers barred at Sneakers Bar snkrs
Sneakers Bar this and bar
s-n-k-r-s do they go to the bowling
alley to buy shoes from you uh either I
ship to them or they come to me at the
ball meet at the bowling why don't you
start a shoe store at the bowling alley
because they need bowling shoes for the
bowl if if you bowl a turkey a Jordan
comes out of the [ __ ] thing I'm in I
thought about doing a custom bowling
shoe for like on a new Jordan too
dude these are cool egg cool stuff man
yeah but where's the bowling stuff
got deleted why nudity no because it was
technically underage because I totally
forgot about it and then uh they it was
under 13 years old and you're not
allowed to have an Instagram page what
do you mean you have a [ __ ] kid that
runs the bowling game huh what no no so
I did the years of how long we've been
open and I didn't think about the age
thing right but then they didn't catch
it until like eight years later so I was
like well that's true so I thought it
was a minor yeah yeah well they're
protecting your bowling alley from
pedophiles so that's a good thing
there's a lot on Instagram there's a
bunch ooh that bowling
what do you like
how's the bowling alley though but dude
thank you for stopping by man I
appreciate it make sure to tell the
story We Wish your community the best to
get your money back get your money back
or your shoes yeah go to his bowling
alley
Dave the bowling alleys save the bowling
alley and we're doing dance competition
we're gonna do a dance competition and
save the bowling alley yes dude the
Kinja and uh Quest merger is gonna
happen there hashtag underage bowling yo
we should do a JK news episode with
dudes bowling around us and we're just
yelling because we just hear [ __ ]
pins breaking in the back
all right
um